[Music]
on this Tuesday night raising the
standards of long-term care after
thousands of covid-19 deaths new
guidelines are out for Canada's Care
Homes it's now time that we just get it
done why critics say it's a first step
but not good enough
BC's overdose crisis whose hardest hit
and the treatments needed
kids teenagers and concussions it was
kind of scary the best remedies for
physical recovery and mental health
plus two countries sharing a shameful
past indigenous people's experience
worldwide needs to be known Sweden's
road to reconciliation with help from an
elder in Winnipeg
[Music]
mobile National with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us it was
not long ago that we were leading the
news with the thousands of people dying
in long-term care homes in Canada as
anyone who had loved ones in a care home
remembers the pandemic was devastating
especially in the early stages Canada's
failure to protect the elderly was
abysmal in May of 2020 long-term care
residents accounted for 81 percent of
all reported covid-19 deaths in Canada
that puts us by far the worst compared
to other oecd countries where an average
of 38 percent of all coveted 19 deaths
in that period were in long-term care
there were calls for national standards
well now they have been created by they
are voluntary and that means despite all
the promises they may make no difference
at all Heather York's West has our top
story tonight
it's been eight years since Amanda
O'Reilly's mother suffered a brain
injury since then Brenda O'Reilly has
been in and out of long-term care in the
last year she's been in two different
facilities I pulled her out of the first
one because I would go in there and
constantly find her uncared for the
crisis that faced Canada's long-term
care system during the covid-19 pandemic
laid a series of system-wide failures
bear across the country facilities were
understaffed unable to provide
vulnerable aging Canadians with an
adequate level of quality Care the covid
situation thankfully is significantly
better it's not gone but the underlying
root cause problems of why Canada did so
bad when it came to the pandemic in
long-term care still remain long-term
care in Canada falls under the purview
of provincial and territorial
governments but now New National
standards have been released outlining a
minimum level of acceptable care two
sets of managers were released the CSA
standards that look at the design and
operation of long-term care homes and
then the hso standards that really speak
to what care and working conditions need
to be like in our Long-Term Care Homes
although these standards now exist not
all long-term care facilities will be
abiding by them only two-thirds of the
country's facilities will be accredited
based on these standards and in two of
the country's largest provinces BC and
Ontario these benchmarks are only
voluntary there's nothing stopping us
other than political will and it's now
time that we just get it done Advocates
would like to see the new guidelines
become part of not only every facility's
accreditation process but the basis for
all subsequent inspections as well I
walk into that facility and I have
strangers who are begging me to help
them and I'm not allowed accountability
measures families like the O'Reilly say
are long overdue Heather York's West
Global News Calgary
when the crisis was fresh in everyone's
Minds the federal government promised
national standards for long-term care
today's announcement is the result of
that but because these are voluntary
these guidelines could end up on a shelf
unless they're backed by political will
today prime minister Justin Trudeau said
this
we recognize the responsibility and
jurisdiction of provinces in these areas
but I think all Canadians regardless of
the order of government want seniors to
have the best quality of care possible
and that's we're going to continue to
work with me from autowise our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes
writing down these national standards is
a first step what about legislating them
though so they're mandatory
well Donna that's where the devil's
really in the details on this there is
going to be legislation called the safe
Long-Term Care Act introduced and that
will happen before the end of 2023
talking about National long-term
standards but these will in no way be
enforced by the federal government it
will be up to the provinces and
territories whether or not they want to
go along with them now that's the
opposite in a way of what prime minister
Justin Trudeau said on the campaign
Trail back in 2021 when he said
enforceable national standards were what
was necessary we are told as well that
when the premiers meet with the prime
minister in coming days about the Health
Care Act and the health care Accord that
they're hoping to get these standards
are not going to be on the agenda as
something that is tied to money so the
provinces are not going to have to agree
to these in order to qualify for
additional dollars and that leaves a lot
of folks saying look everyone can agree
that Canadians want this but when it
comes down to it we still have
politicians pointing the finger at each
other instead of creating enforceable
national standards
you know the NDP Mercedes said
legislating national standards for
long-term care was a condition of their
agreement to support the liberal
minority government so what are the NDP
saying today
well that's a great question because
this is clearly not going to be
enforceable drug meat saying the NDP
leader was up asking the federal
government if and when they will make
this enforceable in question period
today listen to this
after seeing the report the Prime
Minister said he was sad and frustrated
but two years later there's been no
action when will the Prime Minister
legislate standards in long-term care to
protect our seniors
and Donna that's also a question for Mr
Singh and his party if this is part of
their supply and confidence agreement
with the government that keeps the
Liberals in power and it is to have
enforceable national standards for
long-term care homes what will they do
with the government saying that they
don't plan to make these enforceable is
it something they're willing to bring
the government down over that's unlikely
and unfortunately that means the elderly
may be left paying the price
so frustrating Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thank you
now to the Public Health crisis over
deaths from toxic illicit drugs
preliminary results from the BC coroner
service show there were more than 2 200
toxic drug deaths in that province in
2022 the second deadliest year on record
that's just 34 fewer than the 2306
deaths reported in 2021 it amounts to an
average of 189 people dying every month
in 2022 and that means about six people
dying every day the number of lives lost
is hard to comprehend BC is starting a
pilot project that decriminalizes
possession of small amounts of certain
illicit drugs it's hoped it will help
save lives need through garcha breaks
down the Grim facts of BC's drug crisis
a toxic supply of drugs Remains the
leading cause of unnatural deaths in BC
significantly more than car crashes
self-harm and homicides combined
according to BC's Chief coroner
releasing another tragic set of numbers
of fatalities right across the province
three of the five Health authorities
experienced their highest rates of death
ever in 2022. more than 11 000 people
have died in BC since the Declaration of
a drug toxicity Public Health Emergency
in April of 2016. 70 percent of those
dying are aged 30 to 59 but she says
Children and Youth are being
significantly impacted both in
experiencing harms from using substances
themselves but also in suffering the
loss of siblings parents grandparents
and caregivers all right love you First
Nations continue to be the hardest hit
population with more dying from toxic
drugs than from covid-19 According to
the First Nations health authority
seeking treatment alone in the standard
Western format may not meet the needs of
all First Nations people for all who are
at risk some say treatment options must
include a safe supply of drugs we
currently do not have youth dedicated
overdose prevention sites as well as
supervised injection facilities across
this province cities with some of the
highest numbers of deaths in 2022 were
Vancouver Surrey and Greater Victoria
where there's also a high concentration
of international students some have been
sounding the alarm about toxic illicit
drug deaths among their peer groups so
the post-secondary institutions and like
private colleges they are using students
as a cash cow but don't deliver
multilingual mental health and harm
reduction supports within colleges and
universities I think this should be
mandated by the provincial governments
all this comes as BC decriminalizes
small amounts of hard frogs in a move to
stem the seemingly Unstoppable trend of
toxic drug deaths Nito Garcia Global
News Vancouver
across this country there were more than
3 500 opioid toxicity deaths from
January to June of last year BC factored
in illicit drugs but not every Province
tracks the same data and when it comes
to opioids the majority of deaths
occurred in BC Ontario and Alberta 97
percent of deaths were accidental
there's a sign Canada's economy is
losing momentum the economy slowed
through the end of 2022 though it isn't
in recession territory yet the economy
grew just slightly in November at a rate
of 0.1 percent early indicators also
point to the GDP being flat in December
which suggests the economy grew at an
annualized rate of 1.6 percent in the
fourth quarter of last year
those numbers support what many
economists anticipate a recession is
likely sometime in 2023 how severe it
might be is up for a debate one thing is
already clear Canadians are struggling
financially as part of our out-of-pocket
series Emily Mertz spoke with an Alberta
woman who's on a fixed income and has
had to make some hard choices and
creative changes
so three years without work is is has
been a real hardship for me after nearly
four decades as a golfer playing
professionally and coaching Kathy
Burton's life changed dramatically I am
on disability
I've had to sell my car kidney disease a
transplant in 2020 and several
infections then she lost most of the
vision in her right eye two months later
her left the interesting thing with golf
professionals most of us don't have a
pension Burton receives the Canada
Pension Plan disability benefit that
gets her just under 1200 a month not
enough to cover her mortgage
as she adapts to vision loss Burton is
also finding ways to cut costs for an
example
I would make a shepherd's pie but I
would add other ingredients to make it
more filling around the house I keep the
temperature around 15 degrees Celsius it
is overwhelming as I say all those
things but I'm trying my best to kind of
try to figure that out across Alberta
social programs and assistance are in
high demand family and Community Support
Services offers things like homelessness
prevention poverty reduction and aging
in place we talk about families that are
kind of on the cusp right that you know
you know they're just barely making ends
meet well I mean this these are the
times that we're seeing where those
people are not being pushed over the
edge those on fixed incomes are
particularly vulnerable the check that
you receive is it enough to pay for rent
and to pay for transportation and
clothing and food food that's the
question Burton hopes policymakers are
asking themselves they need to you know
come come and sit in my shoes and then
tell me how am I going to pay my bills
just I actually do that Emily Mertz
Global News Edmonton
to France now where Nationwide protests
shut down much of the country again
today it's a backlash to proposals to
raise the retirement age from 62 to 64.
the French President Emmanuel macron has
tried and failed to do this before he
says French people need to get used to
working longer but as Redmond Shannon
reports he is facing an uphill battle
Brave Defiance for workers rights or a
delusion in the face of an aging
demographic for the second time in two
weeks hundreds of thousands of workers
hit the streets and picket lines across
France including teachers train drivers
and even ski lift operators
this Union Leader says government
politicians do not know what it means to
work in a hospital a farm or a factory
French president Emmanuel macro says
change is essential if the country is to
keep its pension system afloat as people
live longer into retirement at 62 France
is an outlier in Europe Spain's
retirement age is 65 the UK 66 but the
British and Germans are moving to 67 and
Denmark plans on raising the pension age
to 68.
in France those in manual or arduous
jobs can retire earlier with special
deals for Transit and utility workers
too all could see some increases to
their retirement age there's of course a
general acceptance that something needs
to be done
but those who accept that idea don't go
on the street those who would lose
although the minorities they go on the
street the complexity of different labor
deals makes a national consensus more
difficult France has a long history of
huge strikes forcing the hands of
lawmakers so macron's minority
government faces a tough battle to push
reforms through the National Assembly I
think the chances are very slim because
the opposition parties really don't have
their own interests on see their own
interest in helping him union leaders
say two more National strikes are
planned for early February Redmond
Shannon Global News London
dozens of funerals were held today and
Peshawar Pakistan a day after a bombing
that killed 100 people most of them
police officers and security Personnel
on Monday a suicide bomber gained entry
to a secure area that included the
police headquarters and a mosque
hundreds of people were gathered for
afternoon prayers when it happened many
are still searching for missing loved
ones the Taliban and Pakistan initially
claimed responsibility and then revoked
it the group has been behind a
Resurgence in violence in the region
in Iran a young couple has been
sentenced to 10 and a half years in
prison for a video they posted of the
two of them dancing
this video was taken in front of
tehran's Freedom Tower in November and
it went viral the woman wasn't wearing a
headscarf which is illegal in Iran and
dancing in public is also forbidden
especially with a man a couple has been
convicted of encouraging corruption and
gathering with the intention of
disrupting National Security their
families say the couple were prevented
from speaking with lawyers and denied
bail
a dangerous ice storm gripping parts of
the U.S coming up how long the weather
system could stick around
after a fairly mild January winter
weather is a game causing chaos this is
Metro Vancouver this bus had a hard time
sliding into a number of vehicles as it
tried to make it down that street one of
the many fender benders causing grief
for drivers the region isn't alone
extreme cold warnings have been issued
for Northern Alberta right across to
Newfoundland and Labrador
winter storm has created dangerous
travel conditions and disrupted
thousands of flights in parts of the
Southern United States
a mix of freezing rain sleet and bitter
cold has been blamed for multiple
accidents at least one death is linked
to the icy conditions in Texas the storm
stretches from Texas to Tennessee and
it's expected to last until at least
Thursday morning
concussions in kids ahead the new
Canadian study suggesting a different
way to recover
there's some new thinking about how kids
should recover from a concussion rest in
isolation may not be best a Canadian
study is reinforcing the importance of
getting children back into a routine
back to school after suffering a
concussion as Catherine Ward reports the
findings may help develop new guidelines
for a faster recovery
Owen Miller lives and breathes hockey
but just over two weeks ago he suffered
a concussion playing the game he loves
unfortunately a player on the opposing
team hid him from behind and he went
headfirst into the boards I had
a bit of a ringing in my ears and a very
sharp pain in the top of my head this is
Owen's first brain injury doctors
encouraged him to get off screens and to
rest it was kind of scary because I've
heard a lot of bad things about
concussions but when it comes to just
how much rest is needed new data shows
getting back to routine has a positive
effect on recovery especially when it
comes to school this study now confirms
that kids who get back even within two
days following their concussion to
school will help those get back not only
School faster but help them with their
symptoms a new report looked at more
than 1600 youth between 5 to 18 years of
age across nine pediatric emergency
departments in Canada the data indicates
students who only missed one to two days
of school had a lower burden of symptoms
two weeks later compared to students who
stayed out longer kids eight and up with
a high number of concussion symptoms
benefited the most from getting back
into the classroom it's important even
if kids are having symptoms to go back
if they can tolerate it even for just
short periods of time just to be
reintegrated as part of the learning
process again doctors say it's critical
for their mental well-being and Recovery
when kids miss school or they stay in a
dark room don't see their friends that
can lead to fear that they're not going
to get better fear of missing out and
increase their worry
when that worry and that fear exists for
longer it's even harder to break that
cycle experts say it's all about balance
so kids like Owen get back to doing what
they love I do hope to keep playing
hockey for as many years as I can
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
Truth and Reconciliation next the
Manitoba residential school survivor
helping guide Sweden
[Music]
it has been seven years since the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission released
its findings a comprehensive historical
record of the residential school system
with calls for Action Now Sweden is
launching a similar fact-finding Mission
and it's asked of First Nations Elder
and residential school survivor from
Manitoba for advice Toria isri reports
Geraldine shingus received an unexpected
email it was the Canadian embassy that
invited me the Winnipeg grandmother had
never been to Sweden before but the
Canadian embassy needed her diplomatic
help this was my first time traveling
abroad I did a lot of research like you
know before I went like you know because
I wanted to know about her their history
a history that started with the Sammy so
they're reindeer people the indigenous
people of Sweden whose traditional
territory spanned Scandinavia and Russia
their stories need to get out there not
just in Sweden but worldwide our stories
are so similar
those similarities Run Deep like
indigenous people in Canada the Sami
were uprooted from their lands and sent
to church-run schools they were not
allowed to speak their own language they
were not allowed to use a traditional
clothes and even though they just tried
to talk to a friend in their own
language they get abused for years the
Sami people have pushed the Swedish
government to collect evidence and
testimony and start a process similar to
Canada's Truth and Reconciliation
Commission the Swedish government
recently agreed to launch hearings which
are expected to wrap up in 2025.
shingu's testified at the TRC and
brought that wisdom to the Sammy
commission last October about her time
as a little girl at muskogan residential
school in Saskatchewan and the beatings
that caused her hearing loss it's a
period in my career that I'll never
forget and I think she did so much to
help strengthen the ties between
indigenous peoples shingus thinks Sweden
can learn from Canada's Mistakes by
encouraging more indigenous
participation and leaning on elders
indigenous saw people's experience
worldwide needs to be known that truth
needs to come out
a painful truth once hidden now spoken
aloud Toria is rate Global News Ottawa
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
candidate is this snowy owl in Regina I
almost can't see it there in the snow
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to us and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]
thank you